не вистачає газу
транспортні потужності в даний час також від
російська сторона в європу
ви налили більше скрапленого газу
потужності, які ми можемо продовжувати використовувати
але газотранспортна система всередині
Україна дуже важлива для
Європа і, отже, його місто
стратегічний інтерес до чого
є і має бути виконано з боку
Європу тоді теж штовхнуть
в цьому відношенні це зараз на даний момент
велика невизначеність, що це є
тема зміщується, і він зміщується
повертатися до цього, тому що нам це подобається
мають велику невизначеність з Росією
але це точно зміниться
це перш за все політичне
оцінка не є ні економічною, ні
це в тому сенсі, що це реалістично
політичне політичне бажання
у росії є приблизно якраз україна
країна транзиту в майбутньому після
можливість обходу
у нас надлишок газу на
міжнародні ринки ми повинні самі
більше урізноманітнити різні
транзитних шляхів і нам потрібно перед усіма
речі також більше рідкого газу та Європи
і все це буде проштовхуватися паралельно
у цьому відношенні питання в тому, чи один
насправді такий дорогий трубопровід swissgas
від прагнення, з якого власне стає 2
потреба досить сумнівна, особливо тому, що ми також у
Європа менше газу в майбутньому
споживає європейське
диверсифікація є ключем
стратегія також постачати газ
забезпечити всю Європу
і ось де це місце
з'єднання Європи з Україною
це також стосується зворотного потоку
трубопроводи також здатні
відповідний із заходу на схід також газ
транспортувати
Європа готується будувати
все більше терміналів зрідженого газу з і
тепер потрібно вдосконалити трубопровід таким чином
що це також можливо в майбутньому
буде